Helen Walters: Last week,
US President Biden
and Xi Jinping, the president
of the People's Republic of China,
met at the APEC Summit in San Francisco.
The meeting was notable
for being the first time
that Xi had visited the US in six years
and the first time the two leaders
have met in person in a year.
Now, obviously, what goes on
between these two nations
matters to everyone.
So we found ourselves post-summit
with a bunch of follow-up questions,
and we've turned to our resident
geopolitical expert, Ian Bremmer,
to help us understand
what to pay attention to and why.
Ian, hi.
Ian Bremmer: Helen,
good to be back with you.
HW: OK, so let's get right to it.
These are, alas, not peaceful times.
And I think it's safe to say
that the meeting between these two leaders
felt perhaps even more momentous
than it might have done
were war not raging everywhere,
from the Middle East to Ukraine.
So tell us,
what happened in San Francisco,
and what stood out most to you?
IB: Well, look, that is the backdrop.
That this is a world of unprecedented
geopolitical danger and risk.
And the efforts are not in trying
to make everything better.
It's rather to try to stop the existing
conflicts from getting much worse.
And that is absolutely the macro focus
that both President Biden
and President Xi bring to the meeting.
I mean, there's a lot to discuss around
the issues around US-China relations.
I'm sure we'll get to that.
But, you know, it's interesting
that insofar as the Americans and Chinese
are actually on opposite sides
of the two major global conflicts
in the world right now.
On Russia-Ukraine,
the Chinese are the close friends,
without limits, to Vladimir Putin,
while the Americans
are providing more support
than any other country
in the world, militarily, to Ukraine.
The Chinese have not condemned Hamas
for their terrorist attacks.
The United States finds Israel
its most important and enduring ally
in the Middle East.
So you would think, Helen,
that this would be an area of contention
between the United States and China.
It's not.
Both the Americans and Chinese
are deeply concerned
that these conflicts
are going to get worse.
And they don't want that.
They want to find ways
to contain these conflicts.
And I think it's a very important point,
because we hear a lot about, you know,
Americans looking for adversaries
around the world
and lumping in China
with countries like Russia, Iran,
North Korea.
And those other countries
are rogue states.
They're pariahs.
They're countries that benefit from chaos.
They want to take advantage
of vacuums geopolitically.
Where the Americans and Chinese actually
geopolitically have a lot more in common,
in addition to the fact that they have
a lot of interdependence,
they also both benefit from a global
backdrop that is stable.
They want relatively free
and open trade of goods.
They want a global economy that's working.
They don't want political
instability everywhere
or social instability everywhere.
And so even though
the United States and China
have different preferred end-states
for Russia-Ukraine
and for Israel-Gaza,
in the near-term,
you've got two leaders
that are meeting and saying,
how do we stop this from getting worse?
And that ended up being a significant
piece of the conversation,
the four-hour, three-session conversations
that Presidents Biden and Xi were having.
In some ways, maybe
the most important takeaway
that the two most powerful
countries in the world
are not looking at the Middle East
and Russia-Ukraine
through a lens of cold war,
but instead are looking at it
through the lens of,
"Oh my God, this is really a problem.
And are there anything that we can do,
individually or collectively
or with our friends and allies
in the regions,
that might help to stop this
from getting much, much worse?"
HW: Can you say any more
about what that actually looks like?
What might those alignments be?
IB: Well, in the case of the Middle East,
China has a relationship with Iran
that the United States does not have.
And both the American cabinet
as well as Biden directly
have been talking to the Chinese
about getting messages to the Iranians
to help ensure that they don’t get
directly involved in the war
and that they limit the support
that they have given
to proxies in the region
that could, for example,
not only expand the war,
but also lead to challenges
in global energy supply.
You know, the Americans
sent two carrier strike groups
to the Eastern Med and the Persian Gulf
almost immediately after
the October 7 terrorist attacks.
China has destroyers in the region,
and they were there
for military exercises.
They’ve kept them there, and
they’ve expanded the military presence.
Not to fight the Americans
but rather to show
that the Chinese want to ensure
that there is not a fight in the region
that would suddenly prevent energy
from getting through
the Straits of Hormuz,
a critical choke point.
So, you know, frankly,
there's more alignment on this issue.
The Chinese also, just earlier today,
as you and I are talking,
hosting a group of foreign ministers
from the Muslim world,
including the Palestinian Authority,
they're talking about a ceasefire
and a two-state solution.
Biden wants an extended
humanitarian pause,
not a ceasefire,
but also a two-state solution.
There's been a lot of conversation
around trying to bring
Middle Eastern countries
to be more constructive in helping
to ensure stability in this conflict.
So around the Middle East,
there's been a lot,
because it's more recent,
and because it’s frankly
more geopolitically dangerous --
the Russia-Ukraine war has more
knock-on economic implications --
but the Middle East conflict
is much more geopolitically fraught
in the sense that you could have
a religious war from, you know,
Ecuador to Indonesia.
Because you could have, you know,
they could have a much greater impact
on the US presidential election,
for example.
That is one that is driving
a lot more direct attention
and engagement from the American
and Chinese leaders together.
HW: So I think it's interesting
and heartening
that stability might be
a watchword at this moment.
The US and China,
they obviously subscribe to very
different political systems.
And I think of a quote from
the MIT economist Yasheng Huang,
who was once quoted saying
that the two countries kind of got married
without knowing one another's religions.
How much did this summit, if anything,
do to address the root causes
of the tension?
IB: You know, it's interesting.
I see the analogy of US
and China getting married
without knowing the families
or the religions or any
of the other, you know,
sort of red lines that one connects with
when you make that lifetime bond.
But, you know, I've always
thought of it as a couple,
that the love has left the relationship,
but they have children together,
and they love the children very much,
and they both want to make sure
that the children aren't hurt.
And so as a consequence, as much
as we can talk about, you know,
derisking as a term of art, or decoupling,
and these countries having very different
political and economic systems,
and they don’t particularly
trust each other,
and yet they know they need
to work together.
So in a sense, they're adults,
geopolitically.
I mean, when you have the US and China
in a room at the highest level,
and here I'm not just talking
about the presidents,
I'm talking about, you know,
any of the cabinet meetings
that have happened
at great level and scope
over the past months
after really none at all
during the couple plus years of pandemic,
all of those meetings,
they haven't been easy,
they've frequently been tense,
but they have all been handled as adults,
handled as two parents
that know the children need
to be taken care of long-term.
And when I say the children,
I'm not disparaging other countries.
I'm really talking
about the collective interest,
the knock-on interests
that come from what happens
if the US-China relationship suddenly
becomes one of cold war or worse,
which is absolutely plausible
in today's political environment.
So if that's the backdrop,
I think that Biden in particular spent
an enormous amount of time
over the last six months
in preparation for this event,
trying to convince the Chinese
that the meeting would go well,
that the Americans were not planning
on dropping any surprises,
on undermining or embarrassing
their head of state
when he showed up on American turf
in San Francisco.
They were very concerned about that
because there's no trust,
and because there are plenty of issues
of significant tension
between the two countries.
And I think that they succeeded
critically in that.
Again, we haven't talked yet
about the specific issues,
and I know we'll get to them.
But the macro backdrop is important.
Over the last couple of months,
China has been on a charm offensive,
with the Australians,
inviting the Australian prime minister
for a state visit to China
just a few weeks ago.
That went extremely well
with expanded trade and energy agreements
on the back of, you know, a relationship
where they weren't talking to each other,
where they were cutting off business,
where they were engaging
in massive tariffs and sanctions.
That's seen a breakthrough.
I've seen some of that in South Korea.
I've seen some of that with the Japanese.
And over a one-hour meeting
between Prime Minister Kishida
and Xi Jinping in person
at the APEC Summit, first time
in over a year that they have met.
I've seen that with the Europeans.
I've also seen it with a large number
of American and European CEOs
who have reported individually
just how much more access they've gotten,
welcoming they've gotten
from their trips to Beijing,
positive press coverage,
movement on issues
that have mattered to them,
all of which a sense that a better
Biden relationship with Xi Jinping,
not a breakthrough, not an entente,
but simply a commitment
that the US wants a more stable
baseline relationship
and would work towards that,
in San Francisco,
that gave the Chinese
leadership permission
to engage in this charm offensive
with other countries
and with the private sector.
And why was that so important?
Well, first, because it lowers
the temperature of the relationship.
It makes sudden, unsuspected crises
less likely to occur,
but also critically,
because the Chinese economy
is underperforming dramatically.
For many reasons, maybe most structurally,
because 50 years of China
acting as the world's factory,
with all of this inexpensive labor, well,
you don't need all
that inexpensive labor anymore.
And by the way, that labor
is not so inexpensive anymore.
And, you know, China hasn't become
an open-governance system.
They haven't moved towards rule of law.
And the Chinese competitors
are a lot stronger,
and their demographics are challenging.
And they've got lots of nonperforming debt
and their real estate sector's in trouble.
And zero-COVID went really badly.
And then they unwound it
but the consumers don't feel
like they've got, you know,
animal spirits driving them right now.
And I can keep going.
But the point is that China
is severely underperforming
in a way that, frankly,
we haven't seen structurally
since globalization
bringing the Chinese in,
you know, really got moving
in the '70s and '80s.
So in other words, Helen,
you and I have never seen
this structural economic headwinds
on so many fronts in China.
And the Chinese are much more
aware of that than you and I are.
So they're very strongly incented,
even if they fully intend to take
Taiwan over the long-term
and they want to be the leading
economy in the world
and they want to dominate
artificial intelligence
and all of these things that Americans
and others worry about.
For the near and foreseeable,
medium-term future,
they’ve got to just right the boat.
They've got to get things stable.
They don't want a big fight right now.
And so I think that the Americans,
being a little more confident,
a little less concerned about, you know,
sort of, China taking over
everything in the near-term
and wanting to stabilize things,
really got you a lot more
than you would have otherwise expected
from this summit meeting
over the last several days.
HW: So it’s interesting to hear you talk
about the economic dysfunction in China.
And of course, I think it’s safe to say
that America is experiencing
pretty significant political dysfunction
at the moment.
But what often goes unremarked is the fact
that President Biden
is actually extending,
perhaps doubling down, on President
Trump’spolicies when it comes to China.
So given that next year
is an election year,
what should we make of that?
And do you think
that the policies will continue?
IB: First of all, that backdrop,
that right now, China's in probably
the worst economic position structurally
that they've been in in 40, 50 years.
But their political consolidation
around Xi is completely uncontested.
And certainly XI Jinping
feels very comfortable
that he's consolidated a lot of power.
The United States, exactly the opposite.
The US coming out of the pandemic,
by far in the strongest economic position
of any advanced industrial economy
in terms of growth,
in terms of productivity,
in terms of leading in technologies
and in terms of lower
inflation than its peers.
But the US political system
is more dysfunctional,
more divided than at any
point in our lifetimes.
And for now,
that certainly is creating
a level of risk aversion
on the American side as well.
So I do think that, you know,
at the same time that you hear
a lot of people say,
"Oh, if things go really badly,
maybe they want to lash out."
Yeah, not for these two leaders
at this point in time.
Other leaders, different countries,
different positions, maybe.
But that's not the way that this
is actually playing out.
Now 2024 is coming out,
and people are certainly starting
to talk a lot more about it.
It's interesting that, as you point out,
the United States on China have policies
that are fairly consistent
across the board politically.
Which is not true for most other issues.
If Trump became president,
Ukraine policy would be very different.
Iran policy would be very different.
Europe policy would be very different.
China, not so different.
There's a lot of consistency
between Biden and Trump on China.
A lot of people thought
Biden was going to remove
the Trump tariffs on the Chinese.
He did no such thing.
In fact, he largely extended some of them.
Furthermore, export controls
on semiconductors,
pretty minimal from
the Trump administration,
expanded structurally under Biden
to the extent that China now really feels
like America wants to contain them
in the most advanced areas
of the 21-century economy.
And the US is also leaning
into industrial policy,
like the CHIPS Act,
domestically and with countries
like South Korea and the Netherlands.
The Chinese clearly would prefer
a Trump policy on China there,
than they do the Biden administration.
And, you know, you can tell this
when you talk to Chinese leaders,
compared to leaders
of other countries around the world,
most of whom have
pretty strong preferences
of whether Biden or Trump is president,
of who they want.
The Chinese aren't sure.
The Chinese are thinking, well,
I mean, if Trump comes in,
there's greater likelihood that American
allies are going to be less aligned
because he'll push them transactionally
on spending more money on defense
or maybe he doesn't care
about the Japanese or the South Koreans,
and he'll put tariffs or threaten
tariffs on anybody, friends or enemies.
Biden's less likely to do that.
But Trump is also a wild card
on negative tail risks
directly with the Chinese.
You know, he was the guy that was willing
to work with North Korea,
but also was prepared to hit them
harder if things don't go well.
Well, how lucky did the Chinese feel?
And I think, you know, the answer
you get is we really don't know.
We don't know who we want there.
So there's a lot of uncertainty
that the Chinese have
about the future
of the American political system.
And there's a lot of uncertainty
that the Americans have
about the future of the Chinese
economic system.
At a time when the interdependence
of these two economies
and, frankly, of their
diplomatic interdependence,
is remaining quite high-level.
We may not be comfortable
with that reality,
but that is the abiding reality
that we're going to have
to deal with going forward.
HW: So you mentioned technology,
and I think that we have to talk
about artificial intelligence.
Now, one of the major
breaking stories this weekend
was the management implosions
and excitement over at OpenAI.
And I'm sure we could have
a whole conversation about that.
But given the implications of AI
rolling out at every level of society,
where are the Chinese
and the US governments on this?
And what did they talk
about in San Francisco?
IB: Well, in San Francisco,
they spoke about starting
a track 1.5 working group
on artificial intelligence,
which means the private sector
and the public sector engaging together.
Which makes sense
from the American perspective,
because, you know, the US is a country
that really does promote
entrepreneurialism
and its private sector corporations,
so much so that a lot of people think
the US is less democratic
than it should be,
because corporations, private sector,
capture the regulatory process
through big money lobbying and the rest.
The Chinese, of course, if anything,
the state captures the private sector.
So the fact that they're willing to have
not just government-to-government,
but government-to-government
plus these big companies
that are, you know, effectively sovereign
when we talk about the digital space,
the platforms they have,
the algorithms they drive
and artificial intelligence
that they are rolling out
very, very quickly.
That's a fairly significant move.
And it comes on the back
of the Americans and Chinese
both sending senior officials
to Bletchley Park in the UK,
agreeing to a set of principles
on safety for frontier AI models,
the AI models that are coming
in the future.
So there is a level of understanding
between the US and China
that they need to share information,
and they need to work together
to avoid some of the worst
negative potentials
from very disruptive AI,
while obviously benefiting
from extraordinary, you know,
sort of, world-changing new productivity,
invention and efficiency.
But there's a really,
really big unknown question
that underpins the rolling out of AI.
Because let's think
about what AI does today.
It's taking, it's these models,
these large language models,
that are taking the entire
corpus of global data,
as we have it on the internet,
as we have it in the digital world,
and is making predictions,
pattern recognition and predictions,
on the basis of all
of that information instantaneously.
And we've never had such powerful tools.
Now, when you have
all of that data at your fingertips,
so you can therefore assess and measure
metrics of the world in real time
and how human beings interact
with it in real-time,
that creates really big questions
about what political and economic models
will be most functional.
So, for example, 30 years ago,
you know, we thought,
well, democracy is definitely
the most functional model.
And the internet, as it rolls out,
is making that more clear,
because you've got all these people
with their access to the World Wide Web,
and that really undermines
authoritarian countries
that want to control information
and it helps democracies.
And that's how you got
colored revolutions or the Arab Spring.
And then you have the data revolution,
the surveillance revolution,
you say, well, wait a second.
You know, governments
that have access to all that data
can actually create, you know,
all sorts of incentives,
both carrots and sticks,
to motivate patriotic behavior,
where in democracies that can create
a lot more polarization.
So now let's take AI and look forward
three, five years, when you've got
large language models
that are tailored to your individual
data corpus on your smartphone.
So everyone has an individual AI
that has all the data on you,
and collectively it has all
the data on the planet real-time.
In that environment,
is a planned economy
less efficient or more efficient
than a free-market economy
with different corporations
that are competing?
We don't know the answer.
In that environment,
is an authoritarian political system
more or less stable
than a democratic political system?
We actually don't know the answer.
I mean, Helen, I know
the answer I want it to be.
I want it to be a well-regulated
free market and a democracy.
But I'd be lying to you, right?
We don't know the answer to that.
And so, I mean, suddenly,
the United States and China
are entering into a world
where a small number of actors
in the private sector
are investing immense amounts of money
and developing unprecedented tools
that will determine,
more than anything else,
the viability and strength
of these two fundamentally competing
political and economic models.
And we don't know which one
is going to do better.
Which one might even win,
or can they both exist,
continue to exist at the same time.
And so in that environment,
you better believe that the Americans
and Chinese both want to have,
you know, a very significant seat
at the head of the table
in helping understand what the hell
is going on with AI.
You need to know that early
so you have some time to plan for it,
to respond to it, to govern it,
to create institutions
and structure around it.
And I think right now both
governments are playing catch-up,
but they understand they need to do it
hand in glove with the private sector.
And my God, I mean,
the events at OpenAI
are absolutely essential
to understanding that future.
HW: I mean, complexity
is the operative word there.
I mean, what is the likelihood?
I mean, many speakers at TED have called
for some form of international regulatory
agency or for some kind of oversight.
What are the chances that we could
actually see that actually happen,
and what are the chances
that it could have teeth?
IB: Well, there are governments
all over the world
that are treating this issue with urgency.
They're making it a priority.
And they're doing that in part,
not only because they know
AI is important,
but they also see that AI
is critically important to things
that they're already prioritizing.
So if you look at Russia-Ukraine,
the future of that war
may well be critically determined
by the ability of the Ukrainians
to use autonomous lethal weapons
powered by AI against Russia.
You better understand that
if you're the Americans
and US allies going forward,
both in terms of getting outcomes you want
and also potentially
destabilizing the region
in ways that you're not prepared for.
The AI-driven disinformation
around the US election in 2024
is an absolute critical concern
for US policy makers
and, frankly, around disinformation
for Israel-Palestine
and who wins the information war,
which, I mean, the Israelis
are militarily doing
what they want to,
tactically on the ground,
but broader information war,
at least presently, they're losing.
Understanding AI is critical
to all of these issues.
It's not just a new space.
And so I think everyone is taking
it very, very seriously.
And they're putting a lot
of resources into it.
There clearly is a level of effort
to regulate AI in ways that align
with individual government goals
and systems
that is different from place to place.
So, I mean, in China,
part of it is we can't allow
the average Chinese citizen to have access
to a chatbot that could provide,
you know, responses on any data.
You know, we can't allow --
there's got to be severe penalties
in starting to talk
about independence of Taiwan
or Tiananmen Square or anything like that.
And these companies have to be responsible
not just for the inputs
but also the outputs
that are coming from these platforms.
Where in the United States, right,
you have the companies
that are working very closely
with the US government
to try to figure out,
OK, what are the areas
that we're going to be comfortable
having significant regulation.
Like for example,
red teaming on how one
can break new models
as they're developed.
Or in having watermarks
that help to determine
whether something is or is not
created by artificial intelligence.
Where in Europe, the focus is so much more
on privacy and data protections
for citizens.
So, you know, right now,
you would say it looks
like they're moving in very,
very different directions.
But that's in part
because we don't yet have
anything close to global agreement
on what artificial intelligence can do.
What are the things
that need to be measured,
what are the things
that we want to promote,
and what are the areas that we need to try
to contain or constrain or regulate?
And I think that there's
a United Nations process
that I'm involved in,
a high-level panel that I think is trying
to make immediate strides on that.
I mean, the report's going to come
out within eight months,
which is light speed in terms
of the United Nations.
But we will see
whether all of those efforts
will get you to pieces
of global governance
like you have the beginnings
of for climate change, for example.
But you had decades to get it
together on climate change,
and you have months to a few years
to do it effectively on AI.
I would say that I am hopeful,
but I am not yet optimistic.
HW: All right, we'll take it.
OK, I want to change the topic.
I want to talk about infrastructure.
So the Belt and Road Initiative
is subject to a lot of debate.
And just as a quick background reminder
for those who don't know,
the Belt and Road Initiative
is one of the most ambitious
physical infrastructure projects
that was ever conceived.
It was launched by Xi in 2013,
and originally it was devised to link
East Asia and Europe,
has since expanded to the Global South
and to Latin America.
Do you think that the US is losing
out to China in this regard?
And what should the US do to counter
potential China dominance
in the Global South, particularly?
IB: It’s certainly true that the Chinese
have far more influence
in terms of their commercial and trade
relations across the Global South
than the Americans do.
In part because they invest a lot more
and in part because those investments
are driven much more
by the Chinese government.
And that's because that's the nature
of the Chinese system.
I mean, if Apple decides to invest
in India as opposed to China,
that decision has virtually nothing
to do with the US government,
maybe at the margins.
But overwhelmingly,
that decision is made by Apple
for reasons intrinsic to Apple.
Where if the Chinese are investing,
certainly if it's a state-
owned enterprise,
it's being coordinated strategically
with the Chinese government.
And even if it's a private-sector company,
there's a lot more alignment
with the Chinese.
So I'm saying that in part
because there's some degree
to which this is not a winnable
fight by the Americans.
The Chinese exert influence
around the world
through their state
capitalist system primarily.
Their power is projected more
commercially than the United States,
which historically has projected power,
a lot of soft power through
its political institutions
and through its cultural institutions,
but also, of course, a lot of hard power
through its military might.
And then, of course, the role
of the US dollar as reserve currency,
which allows you to weaponize it,
get countries to do
what they want that way,
but not through state-directed
trade and investment.
So you could say the Chinese
are in the lead there,
though I would argue
that the size of that lead
has been overstated.
In part because China is no longer
spending anywhere near as much
on Belt and Road as they used to.
And that's one of the reasons
why a lot fewer heads of state
showed up a month ago
at their Belt and Road summit
than did during their summits
before the pandemic,
because they just don't have
the same amount of money
that they are willing to throw
at these countries,
but also because a lot
of the investments they made
did not perform very well.
And as a consequence,
you've got a lot of bad debt
that now they have to restructure
in countries all over the world
where they have really,
really big exposures,
like Pakistan and like Zambia
and like Sri Lanka, I mean,
countries that 10 years ago, 15 years ago,
you were heralding as China's
taking over these places.
And then it's like, oh my God,
what are we dealing with?
Venezuela, right?
I mean, a lot of the countries
that the Chinese are dominating
are some of the worst-performing
markets out there
with debt that is going to be
incredibly hard to service,
especially in a really challenging
interest rate environment.
So I'm not so sure that that
Belt and Road, you know,
sort of, advantage is so critical,
especially because a lot
of that Belt and Road
is in hard infrastructure.
And once you build it,
everyone can use it.
You build a port, you build a railway.
I mean, I'd rather the Americans
build it than the Chinese
because it redounds more
to American shareholders, sure.
But you'd rather the port be built,
than no one build the port.
Because that then leads
to more economic growth.
And if the US is the largest
economy in the world,
the US benefits disproportionately
from more economic growth
around the world.
That's just kind of a reality.
It's what globalization is all about.
But I'm not so sure,
when you talk about new technologies,
now it's a very different place.
Now, the Americans
are leading the world in AI,
and the Chinese are leading the world
in transition energy technology:
electric vehicles,
batteries, supply chain.
And we're seeing that play out
in the fight between the US and China.
So there were some big positives
that came between Xi and Biden.
You've got a lot of military-
to-military direct engagement
in a high level that the Chinese
had resisted before.
And so now the next time you have
an American and Chinese aircraft
five feet next to each other,
near-miss or God forbid,
actually have a collision,
you'll have hot lines
to deconflict that immediately.
And that's a good thing.
And on Taiwan, there were
a lot of conversations.
And now the two
opposition parties in Taiwan
look like they're going to run
on a joint ticket.
They still have to figure out
the final methodology on that.
But if that happens, that means
the guy that, you know,
China thinks of as pro-independence,
that would lead to a lot more tensions,
probably isn't going to win.
That reduces near-term tensions.
That's a big issue.
But the big area of conflict
that has not been addressed
and that is still moving towards
more confrontation is technology.
And here the Americans are continuing
with existing export controls,
and they plan to expand them.
In fact, in the coming months,
I think you will see new export
controls on cloud computing.
And meanwhile, the Chinese
are responding with export controls
in the critical minerals space.
They talked about gallium and germanium,
which, you know,
are pretty widely available
and not so essential for so much
of that supply chain.
But now they're talking about graphite,
which is much more essential
for batteries, for EVs
and where the Chinese
have much more control.
And if those move from licenses
to direct controls,
then you're going to have
a very significant fight
between the United States
containing Chinese growth in AI
and the Chinese containing American
and allied growth in transition energy.
That's the opposite of globalization.
It's less efficient.
It's more expensive, right?
It's industrial policy,
it's not free market.
And it will create a much more tense
structural relationship
between the US and China.
This is the area that we need
to watch the most closely
over the coming, say, six months.
It's where we could end up getting
a much bigger blow up,
despite the level of stability
that both sides are trying to achieve
in the relationship.
HW: So the mention of energy
is obviously salient.
And, you know, the COP conference
is coming up in Abu Dhabi
in ten days' time.
And so I'm wondering, did they
talk about climate policy?
Were they talking about energy?
What happened?
IB: It was part of the run-up
to the summit where John Kerry,
on cabinet and special climate envoy
at state for the Biden administration,
was meeting with his interlocutor
in the Chinese government.
They've engaged a lot of late,
and there's a replacement there.
So Kerry met with the replacement,
which is useful, younger,
not as well-known globally,
but has the portfolio on the Chinese side.
And in the run-up
to the COP summit in Abu Dhabi,
where, you know, the world comes together
to talk about commitments on climate,
there has been more
willingness of the Chinese
to say that they will come up
with some joint plan
to further reduce emissions by 2030
and further invest in transition energy.
But, you know, in reality,
the US and China are fighting more
or competing more
than they are cooperating
in the climate space.
This is one where the Americans
looked at China
you know, no matter what you think
about climate change in the US,
no matter how much
of a tree hugger you are or aren't,
you see the Chinese
putting hundreds of billions
into new post-carbon technologies
and you say, wait a second,
I can't let the Chinese dominate
the world in that.
I want the Americans to do that.
So there is, you know,
some sort of, you know,
virtuous cycle of competition,
even if it's not alignment
and coordination.
Now, the alignment between
the US and China on climate
is a challenging alignment.
It's one where the Chinese
are emitting by far
the most carbon in the world today.
And the Americans have emitted by far
the most carbon in the world historically
and emit much more per capita
today than the Chinese do,
though the Chinese per capita actually
emit more than Europe,
which is quite something,
given how comparatively
poor the Chinese are.
You look at that and you say, well,
neither of these economies
really wants to spend a lot of money
admitting that they're
the ones responsible
and they have to be the ones paying
for loss and damages and transition
for the poorer countries that haven't
had a chance to industrialize yet,
haven't had a chance to industrialize
with carbon intensity yet, right?
And there are a lot of countries
around the world, especially India,
but broadly the Global South,
that really want a very different outcome.
So, you know, China used to be
a member of the Global South.
And this is one --
we haven't talked about this,
but it's kind of a really
interesting point to make.
China is not a part of the Global
South anymore, right?
When they're the leading carbon emitter
and they're the leading creditor
to the world's developing countries
and they're increasingly --
and the second,
the second-lead technology country
in the world in terms of biotech
and new energy and digital commerce
and, you know, facial recognition,
you know, voice recognition,
the list goes on and on and on.
You know, China is not
a developed country,
but they’re not in the Global South.
And part of the reason,
to go back to what we talked about
at the beginning here,
part of the reason why
the Americans and the Chinese
are the "adults" in the room
is precisely because they both
have so much at stake
with the existing status quo remaining.
The Chinese want to change their level
of influence over existing institutions.
They want more voting rights
in the IMF, for example,
but they don't want
to break those institutions.
They want them to persist.
In fact, the Chinese, you know, see
that they're the largest
contributor in the world
to UN peacekeeping operations.
That's an organization the Americans
created at the end of World War II.
But the Chinese are really
committed to it.
Where the Russians,
I mean, you know, basically,
they're the ones
that are sending, you know,
Wagner and their successors in
to countries where nobody can participate.
To, you know, literally,
to ungoverned regions of chaos.
So again, it's not
that we suddenly say, oh,
China is a democracy
that we should really like,
they're friendly, they're cuddly.
No, no, no, not at all.
But they are really invested
in the present global system.
And that is a piece of stability
at a time that a lot of the world
appears to be coming apart.
HW: So one final question
and then we have to wrap up.
And this question came from our community
who also sent in questions for you.
How did this meeting change
your outlook on future relations
between the US and China?
IB: In the near term, it almost guarantees
that US-China relations
will be more frequent
and will be more constructive.
That does not mean that there will be
massive breakthroughs,
but the willingness of both sides
to see that they benefit
when they engage
with each other substantively
at the highest levels
across all of the government.
I mean, it's not just on, you know,
Gina Raimondo in Commerce
going over there and saying,
"Hey, we want to make sure
that Disney and the NBA
can still do business."
That's happening,
it's much broader than that.
It's climate, it's defense,
it's technology, it's the leaders.
And I'll tell you,
this wasn't in the talking points,
but it is important
that Biden and Xi Jinping
privately did talk about the fact
that they need to spend more time
with each other personally.
And, you know, that Biden and Xi
knew each other quite well,
spent a lot of time when they
were both vice presidents.
And that's something
that Biden's pretty proud of.
And he talks about it privately
in a way that, for example,
he never got to know Putin,
and he doesn’t like Putin.
Xi Jinping, he may not trust him,
but he does respect him.
They actually do have a person-to-person
relationship that matters.
And, you know, for two leaders
of the most powerful
countries in the world
that hadn't talked to each other
for such a long time,
spending four hours together
really matters, face-to-face.
And I think we're going
to see more of that,
at least by Zoom, over the coming months.
And we should welcome that.
Irrespective of what you think
of either or both of those leaders,
it's a very important thing
for them to be talking.
HW: Ian, always a pleasure,
thank you so much for your time.
IB: Thank you. Helen.